hey there everybody and welcome to CST
103 I'm mark merchandani developer
advocate at Google cloud and today we're
gonna be talking about what's new in
Google cloud cost management we'll go
over a brief tour of the different cost
management tools that are available to
you and we'll look at what's changed
over the past year now we've got a lot
to cover so I'm gonna go ahead and get
started first things first this URL is
where you can view the billing notes for
all the different releases that have
happened we're gonna go over the ones
that have happened in the last year but
if you need a text version or if you
just want to see the changes make sure
to keep an eye on that URL so when we
talk about cost management we're really
talking about the three key pillars
understand control and optimize so
understanding your cost is all about
being able to see how your costs are
being generated and where they're
trending right controlling your cost is
really about reducing the risk of
overspending and being able to improve
the predictability of your costs
optimizing is really more about focusing
on overspending again control is about
controlling it optimizing is really
about eliminating it and then reducing
waste through some of the
recommendations that Google cloud
provides and finding ways that you can
get the same performance for a lower
cost we're going to look at all three of
these but before we can dive into that
we really need to look at how to
organize your resources and I don't want
to spend too much time on the resource
hierarchy but I highly recommend you go
and check out last year's next talk on
the resource organization and access
management it's a really great talk and
it dives into a lot of detail but the
overall summary is that you want your
resource hierarchy to look a lot like
your organization and that's really
important because as you're trying to
you can kind of see an example here but
as you're trying to dive down into you
know who has access to what projects you
can use folders to break that out the
permissions are inherited downwards you
also want to be able to track your costs
through this same hierarchy so you want
to understand which groups are paying
for which resources or which projects
fall under which categories it's really
important to be able to track that
because as your organization grows you
know you're gonna be able to be able to
say how do I know who paid for what
another really great feature you can
is project labels so you can create
another way of looking at your projects
and you might label them with first say
your environments right so you might
have a production environment in a
development environment and then you can
say the same thing how can I get my
costs for my production environments
well you can grab all the cost for those
labels so it's really important to have
those organized and speaking of
permissions you're gonna see a lot of
permissions for the billing account
themselves I want to go over the roles
that you're typically gonna see but it's
also important to note that you can
actually create custom roles with the
different permissions that you need and
you want to always follow that security
best practice of least privilege right
so making sure that people only have the
access they need and nothing more so you
can create custom roles for that as you
go down the road but to start with
you're gonna have billing account
administrators viewers and users viewers
are only going to be able to see the
cost on the billing account so it's a
great simple role for them to go in and
see how much people are spending users
are actually able to associate a project
with a billing account and that's really
important that you only give that to
trusted users because as your again as
your organization grows you're gonna
have a lot of projects and being able to
add them to the billing account means
that you're actually gonna have to pay
for them so make sure that you have the
right permissions set up and that only
certain users can add projects to the
billing account finally you've got the
administrator who is going to be able to
control everything like an administrator
would and actually is gonna be the focus
of most of the things we're talking
about today because they're the ones who
can look at all the different reports in
the console as well as being the ones
you can contact support so you're gonna
probably start with using those three
roles you might add more roles as you go
on the other thing that's important to
note is that a project owner can see the
costs for only their projects right so
they'll have access to the billing
section of the console and they'll be
able to see the billing reports but will
only show data for their specific
projects you can kind of use that to
your advantage when you're setting up
the permissions for users to be able to
understand who can see what so with your
costs being able to be measured only
because your resources are organized and
because you have these permissions let's
move on to the first step which is
really understanding your costs and the
best way to understand your cost is
going to be to go to the billing section
of the google cloud
so and as soon as you do you're gonna
see this which is the billing account
overview this page looks a lot different
than it did a year ago and there's been
a ton of changes to it we're gonna step
through some of them now but needless to
say it's an overview page right so you
can see a lot of really quick
information about your billing account
as soon as you go back the first section
we'll look at is this new chart that
actually is two new charts that show up
they'll show you your top five projects
and your top five products that you're
spending costs on and it shows you their
actual cost and their forecasted cost so
I mean as far as going to your billing
account and seeing important information
you're gonna be able to see where your
costs are where they're going over the
month just being able to see that quick
view is really helpful in addition to
that we've also added a billing health
check card so this is a card that uses
some of the best practices for our
customers and says hey you know maybe
you want to apply these to your billing
account so that you're able to stay on
top of that well the health of it so one
of the great examples of this is being
able to set up a budget which will
actually talk about in a little bit or
making sure that you turn on big query
export or billing data export to
bigquery we'll also talk about that
later and then one of the other good
recommendations is to have multiple
billing account administrators this can
be really important because as I
mentioned before billing account
administrators are the ones who can
contact support so it's really critical
to make sure that you have you know
hopefully at least two but maybe more
and you have this kind of idea of a
reasonable level of redundancy right you
don't want too many people having access
to your billing account but you also
want to make sure that if one person
gets locked out you're not completely
stuck so one of the first reports that I
want to talk about here is a new one
that's been launched and it's the cost
breakdown report and this really just
gives you a quick and easy to see
breakdown of the net impact of all the
things you know you're spending how the
different discounts or other spendings
affected those and then your final cost
this is a great and very simple chart to
be able to look at any month and
understand here's what I spent here all
the different Google cloud discounts and
there's a lot of different ones that can
happen and then here's what I'm gonna
end up actually paying besides that
there's the billing cost table also all
of this is going to be available in the
console and one of the reasons that all
of these pages of
and it is because a lot of this data has
actually been removed from me Google
Cloud invoices so there's a lot less
data there that's really more the
invoice is really more about here's how
much I need to pay all of these tables
and charts are much more about how those
costs actually came to be and the
billing cost data is really important
the billing cost
table is really just a tabular view of
all of your invoice cost and it's
grouped by the SKU you can quickly
filter by different projects you can do
services excuse you could rearrange the
columns it's a really great and simple
way to break down all the costs and see
how they're grouped you can also export
it to a CSV if you need to do some
offline analysis but this is probably
the first place where you'll be able to
see all those costs broken down similar
to that table
there's the pricing report and the
pricing report it looks very similar but
the difference here is that this one is
actually showing you the cost of all the
different services that Google Cloud has
that actually includes Google Cloud
includes Google Maps platform mg suite
so they're all available in that table
and similar to the the billing cost
report you can move things around and
you can kind of break it down as you
need but you're also able to select to
show all the SKUs for Google Cloud or
just showing the ski is that you've used
so it's a quick way to get the pricing
for all of that data on top of if you
have a negotiated price with Google
Cloud it's gonna show you the default
list price the negotiated price and the
discount there so it's really really
helpful to be able to say okay well
these are all the services cost and just
like that billing report you can export
it to a CSV so that you're able to see
all of that data and you know do some
offline analysis as needed
now the billing documents page is a
fairly straightforward page it's really
just where you go to download invoices
statements it used to be called the
invoices page it's been renamed and
cleaned up and again it's really just
about finding that data and downloading
it this is where you're gonna get the
hard copy for all those documents the
billing reports the actual chart that
you're seeing on the screen here this is
part of the billing reports page and
this is probably where you're gonna want
to spend most of your time right it
gives you a great way to visualize all
of the data that we were looking at
before the table is great because it
breaks down into great detail but it can
be a little hard to digest
right the visualization here is really
helpful and it shows you the
transactional costs on a per day basis
and you can actually break it between a
line chart and a bar chart but there's a
lot of options on this page and that's
where you'll be measuring a lot of your
costs so one of the new features here is
the cost forecast and this has been
added and changed a couple of times over
the past year and it includes long term
cost trends so now it includes up to 12
months and it factors in things like
sustained use discounts so sustained use
discounts will typically have a very
high it'll start off with a very low
discount and then as you go along this
is saying use discount kicks in and you
kind of get this down for its pattern
and then the next month starts and it
goes back up so the forecasting takes
all of that into effect and gives you a
great idea of where all that information
is and what you'll be spending over the
next 12 months in addition to that the
right side of the billing reports
there's all these filters on the right
side and you can drill down into any
specific components that you want when
you change these components it will
actually add it to the URL and then you
know if you make a custom report or
something you can just share that URL
with others so it's really easy to kind
of drill down into an area and then
share that with the rest of your team
there's also been a lot of new features
that have been added to the filters and
one of the cool ones is the invoice
centric view that you can click on so in
the default view you can kind of select
whatever range you want you know last 30
days 90 days or just custom ranges and
that's really helpful but the invoice
view just tailors it directly to your
invoice right so show me the invoice for
June show me the invoice for August or
Judaea August and again it breaks down
that chart so you can see the
information and the costs there but it
really just lets you say okay well
here's all the costs for that month and
how it compares to my invoice in
addition to that filter we've added a
couple other ones this one's really cool
it's location filter right so now you
can actually break down your cost by
where they came from what geography what
region or multi region area all of those
are available here just a really helpful
way to break down the costs in addition
to that we've got maples we talked about
project labels before and these are
resource labels where you're able to do
the same thing right let's let's take a
compute engine instance or multiple
instances and label them all with
production and
in the billing cost reports you can
actually say show me all those
production instances and the costs they
generated really really helpful to be
able to drill down into that level of
detail so I mentioned this before in the
in the health card but what you want to
do and here's a feature right you just
go to the billing reports page you
enable the export to bigquery and what
you want to do is turn that on if you
haven't done it so right now pause and
then go do it because it's really really
important it actually doesn't take data
from before you turn it on which is why
it's so important that you probably want
to go enable it now but this exports all
the billing data at a very granular
level some of the changes that have
happened recently is now that it's
hourly so it has a start hour in an end
hour and then it's all the costs that
have happened for all of the different
things associated with that billing
account it is the most granular data
you're gonna get and bigquery of course
is a great place to do giga analysis and
store data so it's really really helpful
to have that there but you can always
export it out of bigquery if you need to
hook it up to a third-party tool or bi
or whatever it's really helpful to have
and that's why it's so important to make
sure that you enable it because you're
gonna want to be able to see that level
of detail when you do any future cost
modeling or really just to get that
level of analysis on your costs so all
of that really focuses on the ways to
understand your costs I want to talk
about the biggest way to control your
costs right viewing them is great but
being able to control them is also very
important and we're going to talk about
budgets so budgets are probably the
number one tool to actually implement
cost controls and they're really
flexible they're actually very powerful
too so let's go ahead and break it down
starting with budgets the first thing
you can do is well you just kind of set
up a budget and when you set up a budget
say let's say a thousand dollar budget
when you hit that amount it's going to
send an email out to billing
administrators saying hey you hit this
budget but you can actually configure
multiple thresholds right because you
want to know maybe before you hit a
thousand dollars so when you set up a
budget you actually set a threshold and
you'll say fifty percent of a thousand
dollars and then 100 percent of a
thousand dollars but you can also set up
forecasted thresholds so forecasted
thresholds are about when Google Cloud
predicts that you're going to hit that
call
right and that can be really helpful to
stay on top of any surprises so if
you're three days into the month and you
get an email saying that hey Google
cloud thinks you're gonna spend 100% of
your thousand dollar budget that might
be a call to action to go do some of it
so as you set up a budget set up
multiple thresholds and you can set up
multiple budgets as well because you're
gonna want to be able to track different
things speaking of that you can actually
set up filters on the budget so the
budget by default is the entire billing
account but when you actually filter it
down you can choose specific projects
specific product or you can even choose
those resource labels that we talked
about earlier and say ok well show me
here's my production buddy here's my dev
budget here's the you know the budget
for all of my biz dev projects you have
that flexibility in that control to be
able to say well here we'll get
different alerts for different people
the other thing I want to talk about is
the budget API so this is currently in
beta but what it lets you do is automate
the creation and managing of those
budgets that's really important because
you know as you grow and your
organization gets more and more complex
you probably don't want to do all of
this by hand so being able to spend some
time learn the budget API it's really
really critical to being able to say ok
well I set up a new project we're gonna
go ahead and automate and add that to
budgets and creating your budgets and so
on so spending some time here can be
really valuable as you grow so we've
talked about budgets being able to send
out emails to billing administrators but
often times you want to send emails to
other people as well and that's where
this new feature comes in that can
actually let you add up to 5 emails per
budget through cloud monitoring and it's
actually pretty straightforward you just
go into the budget you click on the
little check box that says cloud
monitoring you're gonna set up a channel
and then you're just adding emails to
that an important note here is that you
know while you can just add five
individual emails you might want to
consider adding a group email instead
right so that way instead of sending it
to one person in accounting you're
sending it to a group in accounting or
to a biz dev team or whatever because
you want to be able to say here
send these budget alert emails to this
team but you don't want to have to
constantly add people to the team to the
budget right so it's much easier to
manage the team and something like gee
sweet and then just have that sent out
to that group and then you can kind of
leave the budgets alone so it's a great
way to add additional people to your
book
now that's the basics of budgets but the
real power of budgets come from what we
call programmatic budget notifications
and this is really cool because it
basically lets you hook up your budget
to pub/sub and pub/sub in in this case
is an event handler and it's gonna take
alerts from the budget and they'll send
them off to wherever you want to be and
we've got some sample code in the
documentation that actually looks at
sending it up to cloud functions but
when you when you create a budget you
just click that box very simple you
choose a pup subtopic or you make a new
one and then you can go off and make
your clock function and you know we've
got some sample code like I said a very
popular example of this is sending a
budget notification to slack right so
whenever you're an update when your
budget comes in go put it in a slack
Channel and have an update there simple
but it's just a notification so when you
have Google Cloud functions and other
systems in Google Cloud you can kind of
do whatever you could do with code and
that's really important because you can
actually do you know more advanced
things like let's say you hit a way
higher on your budget than you expected
you could actually shut down projects
you could shut down resources there's
some sample code for detaching a billing
account from a project that's a really
dangerous thing to do right because when
you remove the billing account for the
project any paid resources in that
project might get shut down in a very
unexpected way so be really careful
about that but it's a great starting
point to understand how do I really
control my resources and again it comes
down to your organization what's
important for your organization how do
those budgets come up for your
organization and then what kind of
responses can you have to really putting
controls in place so programmatic budget
notifications are really gonna be the
most powerful way to put cost controls
in your place so talked about
understanding talked about control let's
talk about optimizing cost right this is
the great one because basically you're
gonna end up saving money and hopefully
you're gonna do it without changing
anything and the first thing and
honestly the one of the more common
things I see is that people aren't
taking advantage of committed use
discounts and this is such a huge and
actually really easy thing to to set up
on your account all you have to do is
sign up for them and you'll start to pay
a lot less for some of the resources you
already use so commit use discounts or
sometimes we call them
HUD's are able to help you save on
really great static workloads so if
you've got you know V CPUs Ram SSDs GPUs
all of those at a static level you can
look at and say okay well I'm running a
good amount of that or I'd maybe I have
a baseline of it right you might have
spiky workloads but if you've got that
baseline you can take them out and
purchase a committed use discount for
that amount and then you're just gonna
be paying a lot less for the same thing
you're not changing those resources at
all you're just getting at this kind of
price because you're assigning up for a
one or three-year commitment based on
that so it's really helpful to have it's
really easy to set up and I've actually
just added in beta the committed use
discounts for cloud sequel right the
database is probably not something
you're spinning up and down a lot you
probably have a good baseline for that
so it's just another great way to save a
lot of money and we actually have the
committed use discount analysis report
now again available in the billing
section which lets you just visualize
your usage right so in this case you
have a very static usage it'll show you
what you're using on committed Hugh's
discounts what you could be using and
what's eligible for it and then you can
kind of say well look I've got this flat
workload that's gonna be running for a
year why don't I save money on very easy
way to save money and again no change is
really necessary to your actual
resources that are running so the other
thing that they changed in the last year
with committed use discounts is discount
sharing and this one is probably my
favorite because what it lets you do is
take committed use discounts and move
them to a billing and account level if
you've worked with them before they were
specific to a project right so you'd
have a committee just discount on this
project and one of this and this and
this and as you grow on projects that
can be pretty painful so it's really
great to be able to say all the billing
all the committee juice discounts are
now at the billing account level much
much easier and easier to say oh it's
just spread it across all of our
projects highly recommend you check that
out if you're using committed years
discounts because it's just an even
easier way to save money one of the
other features that's rolled out in
Allen is going to have a lot of changes
coming to it soon is the recommender hub
which is part of active assist it's
currently in beta and it surfaces a lot
of recommendations so you'll see some
security recommendations but you'll also
see some cost recommendations and two of
the great ones
a committed use discount recommendation
right so the analysis report lets you
see it but this one will just tell you
like hey look you're spending a lot here
you could be saving money there and then
another company recommendation is the
compute engine cross family
recommendations so when you're using
compute engine you've got a arrow eyes
which family are using in which sizes
you're using that can get pretty
complicated and this will basically
measure the the amount that you're using
those and say oh look this is a pretty
memory intensive application you're
running you might want to consider
switching to a memory optimized machine
and you'll end up saving a lot of money
there's a lot of great stuff coming to
the recommender hub so make sure to keep
your eye on that so with all of that
being said we talked about understanding
controlling and really optimizing your
cost there's two great sessions that are
also available this week CST 101 and CST
104 you can see a great customer story
of how they use these recommendations to
save money and a whole bunch of other
stuff definitely recommend you check
that out and if you're interested in
learning more you want to chat up to
this URL cloud.google.com slash cost
management because all of the resources
that we talked about and so much more
are there you've got resources guides
quick labs YouTube playlist a bunch of
stuff that really deep dives on these
individual topics so I know it was a lot
but thank you all so much for joining me
and don't forget to enable billing
export to bigquery thank you